et pendant ce temps il ya un mot qui est
banni maintenant russie celui de guerre
en parler relève désormais de la justice
le parlement russe a adopté une loi dite
contre les fausses informations elles
sanctionnent de peine de prison jusqu'à
15 ans quiconque décrédibilise les
forces armées russes on va tout de suite
prendre la direction de moscou nous
attend notre envoyé spécial julie dongle
of bonjour julie merci d'être en direct
avec nous c'est un tour de vis
supplémentaire
cette loi
oui cela faisait plusieurs jours à qu'on
attendait que cette loi soit promulguée
c'est à présent chose faite à la douma
et bien à publier cette loi qui punit
vous l'avez dit de 15 ans de prison
toute personne qui diffuseraient de
fausses informations quant à l'opération
spéciale russe alors cela vise bien sûr
les journalistes russes mais également
les journalistes étrangers qui
publieraient dont qu'il n'utiliserait
pas la rhétorique du kremlin en
utilisant le terme d'opérations
spéciales ou d'opérations spéciales à
but humanitaire cela fait plusieurs
jours maintenant que de plus en plus de
médias ici en russie sont restreints ou
encore bloquer c'est le cas notamment et
bien de la radio echo de moscou c'est
une radio indépendante qui avait ouvert
dans les années 90 et dont le slogan
était une radio libre pour les gens
libres et bien elle a été tout
simplement retirée des ondes idem pour
la télévision sur internet la télévision
doj qui était une télévision libre
également un site medusa je ne vous
ferai pas une laisse liste exhaustive de
tous les médias qui sont restreints ou
bloqués ici tente mais bien elle serait
longue mais cette loi s'applique
également à tout citoyen russe qui par
exemple publierait sur un réseau social
ou alors répondre à une interview d'un
média étranger en utilisant une
rhétorique qui ne serait pas celle du
kremlin et bien cette personne en cours
elles mêmes risques de 15 ans
d'emprisonnement par ailleurs et bien
les arrestations se poursuivent hier
soir avec mon collègue amaral à mehdaoui
nous étions dans une manifestation tous
les soirs à 19h et bien quelques
personnes osent se rendre dans un lieu
de moscou malgré le fait que les
manifestations sont interdites alors je
vais vous expliquer brièvement comment
ça se passe les gens se réunissent se
tiennent debout ne parlent pas ils n'ont
pas de panneau très vite ils sont
encerclés par la police moscovite
ils sont arrêtés en tout hier soir et
bien la manifestation a commencé à 19h à
19h30 et bien cela était finie donc
clairement il y à un tour de vis qui
s'opèrent en ce moment en russie
ma de peur que vous mentionnez julie à
cela s'ajoutent les sanctions
occidentales leurs conséquences pour la
population comment réagissent les russes
que vous rencontrez
écoutez ça fait une semaine maintenant
que nous sommes là au début et bien les
gens n'avaient pas l'air de réaliser ce
qui était en train de se passer est
maintenant bien au fur et à mesure par
exemple que les grandes marques
occidentales sont en train de fermer
boutique ici en russie les gens
commencent à réaliser
petit à petit quel impact cela aura sur
leur quotidien par exemple nous sommes
rendus dans un centre commercial tout à
l'heure où ikea avait fermé hier et bien
on a vu des longues files d'attentes
pour que les gens feu se fournissent en
produits de cette marque les magasins
h&m sont également fermées donc petit à
petit les marques occidentales sont en
train de fermer boutique on voit aussi
maintenant et bien des files d'attentes
devant les banques ou les gens craignent
probablement de perdre leurs économies
j'ai pu parler avec un homme de 70 ans
tout à l'heure qui commentent il a
compris que nous étions un média
français nous a regardé droit dans les
yeux et s'est mis à pleurer en nous
demandant ne nous abandonnez pas
continuer à diffuser cette information
ces sanctions nous les méritons nous
russe on doit les assumer tant
l'opération bien mené par vladimir
poutine est injuste une autre jeune
femme me disait écouter voilà moi
maintenant je ne vois pas d'avenir dans
ce pays j'ai décidé de partir le plus
vite possible et c'est le cas de
nombreux jeunes gens notamment un qui
ont décidé de quitter la russie tente
ils ne voient pas d'avenir soit d'un
point de vue économique soit pour la
restriction de liberté dont je vous ai
parlé un peu plus tôt les billets
d'avion sont pris d'assaut leur prix est
devenu exorbitant et donc de plus en
plus de jeunes cherchent à quitter le
pays cependant cela ne veut pas dire que
tout le monde s'oppose à vladimir
poutine loin de là nous avons pu parler
à aussi à être de nombreuses personnes
qui soutiennent ardemment la politique
menée par vladimir poutine et qui disent
que bien par exemple si les grandes
marques quitte la russie les grandes
marques occidentales et bien c'est bien
simple il se tournait en vrai ils se
tourneront vers l'asie par exemple julie
dongle envoyé spécial à ce coup merci
beaucoup julie d'avoir été en direct
avec nous dans ce journal est de nous
faire vivre ce qui se passe à moscou
c'est important